[Musique]
dans le village de vic
situé au centre des yvelines un panneau
nous l'annoncent dès l'entrée ici se
trouve au musée d'art naïf
seulement depuis 2014 il est fermé donc
on rentre dans ce qui était dans le
temps elle accueille aujourd'hui bon bah
oui là c'est encore fermés puisque les
travaux sont pas sont pas tout à fait
finie donner à la commune il ya 20 ans
le musée sur cet art des autodidactes et
gérée par plusieurs associations
successives
quand la dernière abandonne son
administration revient à la mairie qui
décide de fermer pour mieux réouvrir
après rénovation donc là on rentre dans
la partie qui était ouverte au musée
donc on voit les étoiles qui sont encore
qui font encore accrocher une collection
de 800 toile d'or sur les murs ou dans
les emballages à laquelle s'ajoutent les
oeuvres de la défunte propriétaire des
lieux c'est la vue de la route qui qui
est en dessous du musée avait plus de
fenêtres la façade sa fenêtre le pari
fou d'un collectionneur et de sa femme
qui rachète ce qui était alors une ferme
pour les transformer en musée
il a on se trouve dans ce qui devait
être les tables puisqu'on retrouve ici
les auges à vache avec les chaînes etc
étaient là pour attacher les les animaux
et l'autre pour pour manger le musée
d'art naïf de vic et inaugurée en 1973
la collection de max fourni contient
1500 pièces réparties entre le musée de
vic et la halle saint pierre à paris
aujourd'hui tout repose entre un musée
fermé et le sous sol de la halle caché
au public
objectif pour le maire rapatrier toutes
ces oeuvres ici et créer en plus une
salle dédiée son épouse la pianiste
françoise années quand s'est marié avec
monsieur max fournit la laisser tomber
le piano pour
ehrhart et repeinte puisque c'est ce
qu'a voulu faire dès le départ un énorme
projet de réhabilitation pour la commune
de 380 habitants passionnés par cette
histoire son maire est vrai même de la
raconter avec un espace visite dans les
parties privées où a vécu le couple
parce que c'est elle en étant jeune
peut-être oui on trouve un peu ses
traits j'ai toujours espoir parce que là
on on a à force de chercher des fonds
vont on en a trouvé un peu donc j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir
des mois de septembre arrivée à
continuer à reprendre des travaux il
reprend des travaux intérieurs première
victoire grâce à une aide du département
la réfection de la toiture tout juste
achevé dans la mairie de vic les plans
du futur musée sont prêts le projet a
été réfléchie et imaginé pour accueillir
le plus de visiteurs possible les
plantes effet le permis de construire a
été déposé et accepté donc tout tout est
vrai pour démarrer il manque
un peu le financement pour tout faire on
a on va avoir le financement pour
commencer les travaux
mais est ce qu'on pourra aller jusqu'au
bout pour l'instant c'est le point
d'interrogation
un prêt qui s'élève tout de même à près
d'un million et demi d'euros sans
compter l'aménagement le maire garde
espoir de trouver des mécènes pour s'est
pris au jeu et maintenant on aimerait
bien le voir loi fonctionne et c'est
quand même
un bon cheval de bataille de quoi
s'occuper pendant quelques années
avis aux amoureux de l'art naïf musée
ampli d'histoire recherche financement
ainsi que fin connaisseur pour en
organiser les expositions